Hey, YouTube,
we're so excited about this.
They are one of
the most popular groups in music
with fans all over the world.
Here now with an original,
never-before-seen
performance of "Idol"
from their hit 2018 album,
"LOVE YOURSELF 'Answer',"
here is BTS.
You can call me artist
You can call me idol
Or you can call me anything
I don't care
I'm proud of it
I'm free
No more irony
Since I'm always myself,
they pointed fingers at me
I never care
Whatever the reason you curse me out
I know what I am
I know what I want
I'm never gon' change
I'm never gon' trade
Trade off
Blah-blah-blah
You're so noisy
Talkin', talkin', talkin'
I do what I do
So, mind your business
You can't stop me lovin' myself
Eolssu Jota!
Jihwaja Jota!
You can't stop me lovin' myself
Face off, like John Woo Yu-sen Ay
Top star with that spotlight
Sometimes you become a superhero
Drive hard your Anpanman
24 hours is not enough for me
Confusion is too luxe for me
I do my thang
I love myself
I love my fans,
love my dance, and my what
Inside me
I got tens of, hundreds of myself
I greet another of myself
They're all me, after all
Instead of worrying, I'm just running
Runnin' man, runnin' man
Runnin' man, byah!
Blah-blah-blah
You're so noisy
Talkin', talkin', talkin'
I do what I do
So, mind your business
You can't stop me lovin' myself
Eolssu Jota!
Jihwaja Jota!
You can't stop me lovin' myself
I'm so fine wherever I go
Sometimes I go the long way
It's okay
I'm in love with my, myself
I'm so happy right now
Eolssu Jota!
You can't stop me lovin' myself
Jihwaja Jota!